اجواء الولايات المتحده ملبده باجسام
غامضه اربعه اجسام وبالون صيني وثلاثه
اجسام اخرى حلقت في سمائها تحركات دفعت
سلاح الجو الامريكي الى اسقاطها ومن ثم
تكثيف عمليات الرصد والبحث عن اي انشطه في
السماء قد تحمل صبغه استخباراتيه اذ تم
تغيير اليه عمل الرادارات الامريكيه بعد
اسقاط البالون الصيني ووفقا لقياده الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي اصبحت رادارات ترصد اجسام
طيران اصغر وابطى حركه بعدما كانت ترصد
فقط الطائرات والقاذفات السريعه حاله
التنبيه العاليه اصبحت ترصد بدقه الاجسام
الاصغر والابطا والتي تنتج ترددات عرضيه
منخفضه للغايه على الرغم من ان الولايات
المتحده لم تتمكن من تحديد ماهيه الاجسام
الغامضه الاخيره الا ان قرار اسقاطها ناتج
من تزايد المخاوف من عمل استخباراتي
يستهدف منشاتها العسكريه خاصه بعد واقعه
البالون الصيني اما بكين فما زالت ترفض
اتهامها اطلاق بالون تجسسي على منشات
عسكريه امريكيه معربه عن تغاضيها عن وقائع
مماثله
منذ العام الماضي حلقت بالونات امريكيه
عاليه الارتفاع فوق الفضاء الجوي الصيني
دون اذن من الصين احدى عشره مره تعاملنا
معها بمهنيه ومسؤوليه لتظل اجواء العلاقات
بين امريكا والصين مشحونه ومملوءه بالحذر
عسكريا وسياسيا وفي الواجهه منها حمايه
الاجواء الجويه من اي رصد استخباراتي
علي السمان العربيه